أه الغاز الروسي أه يستخدم لتزويد
المصانع بالطاقة الكهربائية وتسخين
كل تلك الأنواع من الأشياء ،
وترى أم وأوروبا الغاز كوقود انتقالي
للانتقال من الفحم إلى
مصادر الطاقة الأكثر اخضرارًا
، نشهد زيادة هائلة في
حرق الفحم  في أوروبا نتيجة
للجهود المبذولة
لتقليل الاعتماد على الغاز الروسي ،
يجب أن
أشير إلى أن الاتحاد الأوروبي يستورد أيضًا الكثير من
الفحم من روسيا
، وهذا أيضًا تبعية على الرغم من
اختلافها ،
فإن
الانتقال إلى الطاقة الخضراء لن يكون
سلسًا و  لن يكون الأمر
فوريًا
، وهناك أيضًا اعتماد على
المعادن والصلب وأشياء أخرى
يتم استيرادها أيضًا من روسيا ولكن
من حيث المدى القصير ،
فإن
البديل الأكثر إلحاحًا
للغاز الروسي هو إمدادات الغاز الطبيعي المسال ، لذلك كانت إدارة بايدن
أم لا.  كان بايدن في أوروبا مؤخرًا
وقد قطع هذا الوعد بشحن المزيد من الغاز الطبيعي
المسال إلى
أوروبا وهذا سيساعد ولكنه
جزء صغير فقط مما تستورده أوروبا حاليًا
من روسيا عبر الأنابيب  الخط
وهو أغلى ثمناً
وهو ما سيستمر في جعله
مؤلمًا للغاية للمستهلكين الأوروبيين
الذين يقولون إنك تعلم أعتقد أن بريطانيا
شهدت زيادة بأكثر من 50 في
تكلفة التدفئة أو تكاليف الغاز
في الأشهر الأخيرة أم
لذلك  سيستمر الشعور بالألم ،
ولكن هناك كما تعلمون
حاليًا ، تدير أوروبا
خطوط أنابيب الاستيراد الخاصة بها من الجزائر والنرويج
بسعتها القصوى ، لذا
فإن الجهود التي يحاول الاتحاد الأوروبي بذلها
لمواجهة
[موسيقى  ]
لذلك سوف يتفاعل السوق بطريقة واحدة
مع الأسعار المرتفعة بشكل صحيح ، فهم ليسوا أشخاصًا
لن ترغب الشركات بالضرورة
في ملء المخازن عندما يكون الغاز
مرتفعًا للغاية وعندما يشتبهون في
أن مشكلة الغاز يمكن أن
تغرق السوق بسعر أرخص بكثير  الغاز في
مرحلة ما ، لذا لن تقوم الشركات بهذه
الأنواع من الاستثمارات بمفردها ، لذا فإن
الاتحاد الأوروبي الذي
أنشأه سوف
يفرض على
الدول أن تملأ وأن تملأ الشركات
المستودعات
هم يفكرون أيضًا في عمليات الشراء
المشتركة للغاز ، لذا فهم يبحثون عن
طرق مختلفة لتخفيف
سلوك السوق الذي سيؤدي إلى تفاقم
المشكلة ،
ولا يعد أي من هذه الأشياء سهلاً بشكل خاص ،
لكنني أعتقد أن
هذه الأنواع من التدابير
تمثل الوعود  من إدارة بايدن ،
فأنت تعلم أنه ليس فقط شحن الغاز الطبيعي المسال إلينا ولكن
أيضًا محاولة بذل جهود دبلوماسية
لإهت تحويل الإمدادات التي كانت مخصصة
لليابان أو تأمين الإمدادات من
أماكن أخرى
أمر مهم لأنه
أمر تعلم أنه كبير جدًا  أزمة أمن الطاقة
التي تعلمون أن
الحكومة تتدخل فيها وتساعدكم في
تنسيق
سلوك الشركات
والأسواق ربما من المحتمل أن تخفف
بعض
المشاكل هناك ولكن أم
أنها ستكون مؤلمة للغاية أعني في
ألمانيا  لقد كان يتحدث عن
التقنين ، ولا يمكنك أن
تجد بين عشية وضحاها مجموعة من هذه الإمدادات
من أماكن أخرى عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالاستثمار طويل الأجل.  إليك
سؤال مختلف تمامًا هناك وهو
أهداف المناخ الخاصة بالاتحاد الأوروبي ، لذا
فأنت تعلم أن بناء محطة Lng
قد يستغرق بناؤها عامين شيء واحد
واستثمار كبير ولكن
حتى هذه البنية التحتية تهدف إلى
جعلك تعرف العمل من أجلها  20 عامًا
عندما تتحدث عن خطوط الأنابيب أو
تطوير الحقول الخضراء ، فهذا
استثمار أكبر
لفترة أطول من الوقت ، وقد
أشارت أوروبا إلى أنها تريد تسريع
انتقالها إلى أشكال أكثر اخضرارًا
للطاقة وإزالة الكربون من اقتصادها لذلك
هناك  سأكون مترددًا ما زلت أعتقد
أن الاستثمار في
طرق أخرى لإطلاق العنان لمصادر جديدة للغاز ، كما
يقول